so this is the box prints yeah and the
thing about that is that there's a cat
that you know goes in the box
well you don't take direction well do
you thin comes across no I don't
remember our cat saying ow
- meow but not out and so follows this
cat in a box to a kingdom of boxes and
cats that you know are in boxes and this
is why I don't chew gum while doing
these because that just sound like you
know like norm of Donnell or something
you know and yeah so he tries to just
help this kingdom of cats because
they're sort of a prince in the pulper
thing going on where these two cats
apparently switch places and Jake gets
something stuck in his teeth there you
go
much like you see here these two look
very similar one is trying to take the
place of the other you know clearly one
doesn't speak the language but you know
so yeah and then at the end financially
is is this even a kingdom like at all
and it's probably not it's just a bunch
of cats running around though I don't
know how they would change the facial
expressions on the boxes but yeah and
jake decides to let the thing that's in
his teeth
stay in his teeth and that's the end of
the episode what have we learned you
know cats really like boxes so yeah this
episode um
this episode I've learned just exactly
that the cats like boxes totally more
than I thought they would so yeah okay
um when this episode started off I was
were actually count really excited
because I like cats I like both dogs and
cats a lot and the idea of just seeing a
bunch of mogera I thought was great I
love the idea of just cats in boxes then
this whole box kingdom and they made a
whole thing out of in this bag story of
the prince or the yeah the prince and
the imposter and I think around the
point of the jousting I finally just
said this is really stupid I'm glad they
start what the direction they did where
he's like it's this even the kingdom
because that's sort of what I was going
to like I think this is just a bunch of
cats like somebody made this box get
together it's but okay I mean obviously
they had to have some ingenuity because
they had to tape stuff together like for
jousting and stuff oh no is this a
brilliant episode of really dumb or a
baby phone I don't know um yeah so let's
say you can't Prince Prince get my box
back yay oh oh don't be so sad come on
up yeah that's right buck up box
Jason stop eating yourself so much like
this episode this is turning out really
stupid nobody what was a good a good
idea to start yeah start off is a good
idea not that well thought out I mean
you can see this side up is upside down
so we couldn't even get the side of the
Box right
it's hot in there well yeah meow
I liked the episode digit you didn't
think I got a little boring there in the
middle no especially wouldn't finished
you know talking to the cat and the cat
is explaining what's going on it's very
clearly pooping yeah I like that stuff
is great and he's reading too much into
it but found the point with the jousting
weren't you kind of going alright but
serious look like or did you think that
was just part of the joke that they just
kept going that long I think it was
partially part of the joke but I can
completely understand people getting
annoyed or bored with it
good kitty you think he's gay uses the
litter box no here's like slaying any
boxes okay
no I mean it I can understand completely
people being annoyed and things already
in the box
I know I didn't board with you though
showed people they got see the can of
the box um see tail oh sorry sorry dude
um but for me I mean I'm a cat fan not a
fan that much of dogs so when I see a
low budget really so when I see a whole
bunch of like cats doing cute funny
things I like it no I stay away from the
Internet now even the cat video so you
can stay away from those cuz it's not my
cat
but you can watch these cats they're not
real
just imagine the ones online are not
real they're bubble gum yes they're made
up I'll see you even the cats like
you're a moron
Greg kitty it digs idea right what never
took Dukes idea Yeah right there bet
that's gonna be a cam video now see you
say you ain't can't be isn't now this is
going to be a cat video I didn't create
this you did you did it you're the one
that wanted the Box on your head on my
head down on my lap okay well you still
put down there for the cab to get into
the bottom line it's it's a cute idea if
you love cats I think you'll be fine if
not it might get a little even though
story with Jake is just like so
pointless well yeah I get
no I know is the idea I I got that but I
mean I did like but what I really liked
was the end
we're being most like this is so
pointless
yeah battle so unfulfilling I love that
because that's kind of what the whole
episode was yeah I was like a build-up
build-up oh nothing actually happens
well that was yeah you know I two
favorite things in it actually is before
the can't even pop up I love when he's
at the window and they runs towards Jake
II just see that background of lines
going to the head he does that going
back and forth yeah all gives lines yeah
um and I love it when Jake just handsome
the nachos and Finn's like nachos I love
nachos I don't know what I love the
light he's animated looking at those
nachos is almost like he's just given
you know a newborn baby like oh I'm on
the ground if that's what you do to new
more babies yeah no to nachos if you
didn't know where babies out there but
you do it - nachos that's the word
there's never said you said use given
like a newborn baby so what do you do
with newborn baby you drunk mother grant
I was confusing it for dropping but
nachos um no yeah well pretty close okay
yeah the baby's on the ground who cares
yeah but I did like BMO asking you what
did cats ever do and I thought he was
having like you know flashbacks or
something but now it's just a not Jonas
- yeah or gum
so yeah I'm gasps black cuz I love the
first half you know and then it just
kept going and going and I oh yeah I
know that's part of the joke and I know
that's life a lot of people would
probably like it you know it just so I
finally saw the child think I just wanna
shout okay I'm done like I'm really done
this is so stupid like this is wasting
my time that I'm not a junkie about but
I love the whole like caution the brake
thing with the spray bottle because I
see as Missouri
yeah and then he comes like and it gets
a goo yeah cats are like that and I like
the cats all piling on it mister like it
was cute but yeah you go down there
fuzzy but so yeah yes it was cute you
like cats you'll probably like it yeah
I'd say if you want cats honestly I
think like as I just said with a cat in
a box on your well I love my cats yeah
that's what I don't love all cats you
just love your cat and cartoon cats mmm
all cartoon cats and Alexa l've Esther
continually chasing a dream that it's
never gonna happen your kids not exactly
the brightest bulb either look at me
still in the box it's like waiting for
something to happen this this cat
according to you is smarter than
Sylvester dude let's do the books stop
throwing your voice sorry
look at how cute he is somebody put this
under YouTube and get a million views no
don't my wait we need a final there you
go fun one more time oh did your
Valentine's Day card shut up